[Musique]
la chirac bonsoir les français sont
convaincus de l'importance et de l'enjeu
de cette élection présidentielle parce
qu'ils savent que c'est de leur avenir
qu'il s'agit de l'avenir leurs enfants
aussi ce possible beaucoup de questions
que souvent elle va pouvoir poser aux
candidats eux mêmes et il se trouve que
lors de votre campagne dans un certain
nombre de meetings vous avez répondu un
certain nombre de français qui vous pose
est directement ces questions à leurs
jours et que l'on revienne sur certaines
d'entre elles et notamment sur le
chômage par exemple le chômage c'était
une question que vous posez une jeune
étudiante c'était à evry
[Musique]
jacques chirac les jeunes actuellement
aspire à être adulte autonome
c'est-à-dire avoir un travail sur être
impliqué à fond dans la vie active est
actuellement là la seule réponse de la
société elle et les tuques le lestage
est-ce que vous ne croyez pas que qu'une
société qui n'apportent que ce type de
réponse là ne ne s'achemine pas vers une
révolte et non choisie que la seule
réponse qu'apporte la société
heureusement n'est pas les tuques ou les
stages l'emploi c'est d'abord la
croissance c'est à dire l'activité de
nos entreprises qui seul crée de
véritables emplois
d'où la première priorité de toute
politique sociale c'est de donner aux
entreprises leur chance et c'est
pourquoi nous avons engagé une action
pour diminuer les charges des
entreprises qu'elles soient fiscales ou
bureaucratiques pour les libérer de
façon à ce qu'elles investissent
davantage produisent davantage vente
davantage et créer davantage d'emplois
et puis il ya naturellement la formation
il n'est pas normal de voir trop de
demandeurs d'emploi avec une formation
qui ne débouchent sur rien ou au
contraire des demandes d'emploi qu'ils
ne sont pas satisfaites faute de gens
formés pour cela
d'où la nécessité d'ouvrir notre système
d'éducation et de formation sur la vie
de créer les filières qui permettent de
donner la formation nécessaire aux
emplois qui existent vraiment
c'est une grande ambition hausse et puis
enfin il ya naturellement je dirais les
moyens du bord ce que vous appelez les
tuques lessivé paix et les stages de
toute nature
mais il ne faut pas les critiquer
d'abord parce qu'il vaut mieux faire
quelque chose que rien du tout et
ensuite parce que il y a grâce à ce
système
beaucoup beaucoup de jeunes qui au terme
de ces stages trouvent un emploi entre
la moitié et les deux tiers et c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle pour
la première fois depuis 20 ans
maintenant
15 ans tous les cas depuis mars 87 le
chômage a commencé à baisser et celui
des jeunes a baissé de près de 10%
je suis fier de ce résultat même si ce
n'est qu'un début
et si par ailleurs j'ai pour véritable
obsession
l'idée de trouver des solutions et la
solution essentielle c'est la relance de
notre économie et c'est cela que je veux
faire et c'est par là que nous
trouverons une solution au problème de
l'emploi à l'autre un autre sujet
jacques chirac qui inquiète les français
c'est la protection sociale sécurité
sociale régimes de retraite
une question d'ailleurs qu évoquer avec
vous après taye le professeur k chirat
dès ma question je communiste à la
suivante pensez vous que le système de
couverture sociale français dans les
structures qu'il a aujourd'hui pourra
faire face aux défis nombreux qui
l'attendent pour les prochaines années
oui monsieur le professeur il fera face
le général de gaulle a donné à la france
le système de protection le plus élaboré
le meilleur du monde et nous y sommes
tous profondément attachés
vous n'avez pas la tentation d'instaurer
un système de sécurité sociale à deux
vitesses pas un instant c'est à l'opposé
de toutes mes convictions mais je dirais
en revanche qu'il y a des problèmes nous
avons réglé tout ce qui touchait la
famille qui touchait les accidents du
travail qui touchait la maladie et nous
avons équilibrer nos comptes ce qui est
capital pour demain reste la retraite et
il ne faut pas croire ceux qui vous
disent que c'est pour l'an 2000 c'est
pour cette année il n'est pas question
pour nous d'augmenter l'âge de la
retraite
il n'est pas question pour nous de
diminuer les pensions par conséquent
nous devons trouver le financement qui
manque et c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai voulu non pas dans cette affaire
contraindre mais convaincre et consulté
préalablement les personnalités
compétentes celle du conseil économique
et social
mais cette question sera réglée en temps
voulu c'est à dire avant la fin de
l'année et la solution il sera apportée
ce que je peux garantir naturellement
c'est le paiement de toutes les pensions
ce que nous avons marqué par
l'actualisation c'est à dire
l'augmentation de façon à ce que le
pouvoir d'achat des pensions soit
évidemment respecter autre sujet de
préoccupation des français jacques
chirac mais sur la politique familiale
si madame eux hennequin à metz que vous
avez interpellé lors d'un meeting
non
et en tant que mère de famille j'ai
peut-être un esprit plus terre à terre
alors je voulais vous demander vous avez
l'intention de doubler l'allocation
d'éducation parentale est ce que ça va
pas se faire un peu au détriment des
allocations familiales et éventuellement
augmenter nos impôts
non madame hennequin ça ne se fera pas
au détriment de quoi s'agit-il
chacun comprend bien aujourd'hui que la
politique familiale est une priorité
absolue et qui doit être reconnu portel
d'abord parce que c'est au sein de la
famille que se développent les vraies
valeurs celles de responsabilité celle
d'amour du prochain celle de tolérance
qui cimente notre société ensuite parce
que nous voyons bien que nous n'avons
plus assez d'enfants et c'est vrai pour
toute l'europe et qu'il faut redonner
une impulsion nouvelle à notre
démographie pour ceux qui le veulent
bien d'autres mais il faut les inciter
en tous les cas ne pas les décourager
dans ce contexte il ya naturellement
toute une politique familiale touchant
les prestations familiales touchant la
fiscalité touchant le logement touchant
les personnes âgées
mais dans ce contexte il y à un élément
qui est important c'est celui qui
consiste pour les femmes à conquérir
cette liberté nouvelle est nécessaire et
à laquelle elles ont droit et qui
consiste à pouvoir choisir librement
entre travailler à l'extérieur ce qui
est le cas de 70% d'entre elles mais
alors il faut qu'elle ait les moyens de
faire garder leurs enfants garde à
domicile ou garde dans des systèmes
collectifs de crèches mais les moyens ou
alors qu'elle le veuille et qu'elle
puisse rester chez elle pour assurer
l'éducation de leurs enfants
mais alors il faut reconnaître qu'elles
font un métier probablement d'ailleurs
le plus beau du monde et cela mérite
rémunération et droits sociaux et c'est
dans cet esprit quand 80 j'avais créé à
paris l'allocation parentale d'éducation
en 96 gelé élargie dans son ensemble à
la france
j'ai indiqué qu'il fallait maintenant
faire un pas de plus c'est à dire
l'augmenter c'est à dire la portée pour
une mère de trois enfants et pendant
trois ans non plus à 60 % du smic comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui mais à 100%
c'est à dire à la valeur du smic
et ce n'est qu'un pas encore vers un
objectif plus lointain bien entendu et
qui est le salaire de la mer rouge
c'est légitime vous avez fait cette
annonce l'action aig se souvient c'était
un peu un tollé on a parlé de promesses
inconsidérées au début de la campagne
est-ce que vous avez véritablement les
moyens du financement de ces allocations
c'était une mauvaise polémique
cette réforme coûte 3 milliards et demi
de francs le budget familial et 235
milliards de francs je vous laisse en
tirer toutes les conclusions
mais la famille est une priorité absolue
alors autres sujets d'intérêt pour les
français bien sûr tout le monde en parle
c'est l'impôt à la pousserait société la
peau sur le revenu c'est guy vasseur qui
est agriculteur et qui vous pose la
question c'était à orléans
[Musique]
monsieur le premier ministre je voudrais
en revenir aux aspects fiscaux parce que
j'ai l'impression qu'il faudrait tout
faire à la fois d'une part réduire la
tva pour pouvoir la rendre compatible
avec l'échéance de 1992 le marché unique
européen
d'autre part l'impôt sur les sociétés
pour améliorer la compétitivité des
entreprises et notamment à l'exportation
alors jacques chirac est ce que c'est
possible
quel choix quelles priorités et aussi
l'impôt sur le revenu des personnes
physiques naturellement savez jusqu'en
60 13 74 les français en général
payer à peu près les mêmes impôts que
leurs voisins européens
et puis il ya une dérive fortement
accentuée par les socialistes et l'on
est arrivé à un niveau de fiscalité qui
ne nous rend plus compétitives
concurrentiel il faut donc réduire cette
fiscalité qui paralyse les travailleurs
les entreprises les consommateurs
français pour éviter en faisant
remarquer autre jour qu'il avait b6 en
1985 à sa demande
chez françois mitterrand affirme quelque
chose qui n'est pas tout à fait exact
dont on ne peut pas demander une
certaine compétence économique à tout le
monde ne nous feront pas ce débat il
faut donc diminuer les impôts dans quel
ordre
et comment d'abord l'impôt sur les
sociétés et l'impôt sur le revenu des
entrepreneurs individuels pour qu'il
soit apte à assumer la concurrence de
l'année 92 93 ensuite tout en même temps
l'impôt sur les personnes physiques qui
reste trop belle nous l'avons fait pour
les plus démunis
plus de 4 millions de familles ont
bénéficié en tout ou en partie de la
suppression de leurs impôts il faut le
faire pour les revenus
moyen est plus élevé de façon à ne pas
stérilisé l'initiative notamment de
notre personnel d'encadrement et enfin
il ya la tva nous avons commencé avec
l'automobile les motos les disques les
médicaments les cassettes il faut
poursuivre je dirais que c'est un
troisième priorité notre programme qui
consiste à planifier 15 milliards de
réduction de déficit de ce déficit que
nous ont légué les socialistes et 15
milliards de réductions d'impôt chaque
année nous permettra d'atteindre
l'objectif que nous voulons atteindre
c'est à dire quand 92 93 la france soit
compétitive que la croissance puisse se
développer et qu'on règle notre problème
de chômage mais cela suppose
naturellement une énergique tenu de nos
dépenses et bien comme je lé fais à
paris comme je n'ai fait depuis deux ans
au plan national
vous pouvez compter sur moi je reviens
sur un autre sujet et intéresse
également les français sur lequel
natalie von vous avez posé une question
à marseille lors d'un meeting c'était la
sécurité
[Musique]
monsieur le premier ministre je suis
jeune comme vous pouvez vous en rendre
compte
par conséquent j'aime bien sortir le
soir et malheureusement l'insécurité
règne de plus en plus autour de nous bon
je l' ai malheureusement vécu
personnellement et j'aimerais savoir
s'il ya un moyen pour lutter quand cela
nous on nathalie pas de plus en plus
vous savez j'ai une fille qu'à votre âge
et je comprends ces inquiétudes
elle me les transmet aussi et lorsqu en
qualité de maire de paris je me promène
dans les rues je vois les personnes
âgées
j'ai toujours peur qu'elle soit agresser
par un voyou qui essaye de leur prendre
leur sac ou leur portefeuille
lorsque je vois dans certaines rues les
appartements les boutiques régulièrement
cambriolé je suis directement concerné
nous avons fait un effort considérable
nous avons fait voter par le parlement
les lois qui s'imposent et nous avons
augmenté sensiblement les moyens de la
police charles pasqua ministre de
l'intérieur a affirmé sa volonté
politique de lutter contre la
délinquance la criminalité contre le
terrorisme et ceux ci ont déjà très
sensiblement reculer renversement de
tendance a peu eu un intervenant
non non ça ce n'est pas exact et nous
continuerons nous continuerons avec la
ferme volonté d'arriver à ce que cette
première des libertés la liberté d'aller
et de venir de posséder sans être
agressé sans être détroussés soit
réellement respectée je n'ai aucune
indulgence pour les criminels et je
souhaite faire en sorte que chacun
puisse se sentir en france en sécurité
ça demandera quelques années mais nous y
parviendrons
[Musique]
oui